ellen can she rebound after backlash
over allegations of a toxic workplace
the talk show is back for its new season
a week from monday
in a statement the emmy winner said i
can't wait to get back to work and back
to our studio and yes
we're gonna talk about it et has learned
that since ellen apologized to staff
members
morale on the show has improved so what
can we expect
well tiffany haddish will join ellen in
studio to help kick off the new season
that was hot and ellen's dj twitch will
also guest host
upcoming episodes now a tiger king
mystery
a new investigation into the
disappearance of carol baskin's husband
was the baskin's handyman involved he
said if you try to leave me again
i will put you in the grinder like i did
dawn in a meat grinder
yeah kenny farr's ex-wife makes that
claim
on 48 hours suspicion tonight on cbs
i should point out that just this
morning after months of trying
we finally heard from her ex-husband
kenny farr
he says i had absolutely nothing to do
with don's disappearance
or any knowledge of it police also told
the news magazine
there are currently no suspects or
persons of interest in the case
do you think this case will ever be
solved
i kind of have a hunch that it will be
and i'll tell you why
because it's gotten so much publicity
next an update on simon cowell i know
the base on the mend
and i still wouldn't count them out for
the finale
tonight on agt six acts will get cut
howie continued his mean streak heidi
there were a couple moments especially
with the acrobat with the chains
and i almost wanted to yell simon at the
tv
when i heard how he speak right for how
he just say that this was not good i
don't get it either i mean
well he has to run the right also to say
what he thinks
but that doesn't mean that he's right
exactly he's wrong
the last time you came you said you were
going to do a trick where you broke your
neck the last time oh so you wanted him
to break his nose
but there was just more danger i'm not
going to
you know die for entertainment literally
you know
but i felt that i pushed the boundary on
the danger side for sure